bonsoir
oh non non non
[Musique]
c'est plus beau téléviseur jamais juste
les films qui sont sur leur pas mal non
plus livre de l'aja n'y va jamais
premier film j'ai vu quand j'étais
enfant nous vrai livre de la jungle
ouais le vrai vrai qu'avec ça beau
moment vous êtes connu dans le monde
entier nous japon partout on s'en rend
pas compte on a toujours l'impression
d'avoir été connus bien que troisièmes
ils nous connaissent
autour desquels je suis extraordinaire
avec vous si vous avez été extrêmement
fidèle à votre artistique
on fait ce qu'on aime en fait ouais
c'est pas faire autrement on n'a jamais
pu faire autrement ce qu'on pouvait
faire
on a fait que ce qu'on est importante
c'est de faire ce qui nous ressemble
s'est trouvé que ce qu'on a au fond de
soi mad être juste avec soi même pas
trichet s'était nous en donner telle une
grande fidélité avec votre vos choix
artistiques mais on pouvait pas faire
autrement
ouais ok pas de mérite aux c'est comme c
est notre vie allait quand même ça se
joue comme ça je dis pas de l'année de
l'orientalisme ça vient d'où cette
espèce de folie du bar --du du bongoïsme
c'est c'est parce qu'on est devant toi
tu viens pas du havre c'est sûr ça a à
voir avec ça la tenue de trois noms de
vendée de vendée et comment on peut se
retrouver à pareille
bon on va être un outil les bateaux les
bateaux en mer les voyages dont j'ai
toujours rêvé quand j'étais enfant je
lisais quand je serai grand je voyagerai
toujours adoré les voyages et cdc des
souvenirs de voyage
rêve les rêves d'enfance où j'ai besoin
de temps en temps on est allé de trois
fois vous devez être fous contre bari
valable pour retrouver tout ce qu'on
aimait puis on y aller sans savoir ce
qu'on allait rencontrer on a découvert
le tout le cinéma indien qui est
fantastique
toutes les religions indienne et c'était
le choc peau c'est un monsieur très
important ici comme choc culturel donc à
une ça c'est évident l'anpaa le cinéma
indien le yéyé c'est important cd oui
c'est différent et françois nicher là
partout on admet les magazines
tous les journaux saluent les taux dans
tout ça j'avais tout le cinéma sim
américain mari elvis ou comme pour
beaucoup de gens c'était notre rêve
c'est pas le moment cet oiseau biblique
bible et ces jeunes garçons les abeilles
comment es tu toi fais des photos avec
eux
thomas on l'a rencontré en 90 comme
modèle et petit à petit on a travaillé
ensemble quand je suis assistante lycée
le rencontrer deux ans
[Musique]
on peut tuer
mon statut
[Musique]
m
on
chiche
[Musique]
ma mère
je suis heureux de voir que ça va on
s'est vus il ya vingt ans pour façade il
ya dix ans pour ban milliers en soi
disant plus d'infos paris dernière mais
ça va je prends des nouvelles c'est
comme la famille fasse entendre des
nouvelles c'est comme une tente et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars dit
yves abonnez vous il m'était impossible
eux